if our objective is to keep the mean
squared estimation error small then the
best possible estimator is the
conditional expectation but sometimes
the conditional expectation is hard to
calculate maybe we're missing the
details of the various probability
distributions or maybe we have all the
distributions that we need but the
formulas are complicated
after all the conditional expectation
can be a complicated nonlinear function
of the observations for this reason we
may want to consider an estimator that
has a simpler structure an estimator
that is a linear function of the data
and then within this class of estimators
find the one that results in the
smallest possible mean squared error in
this lecture we will formulate this
linear least squares estimation problem
and then solve it we will see that the
solution is given by a simple formula
that involves only the means variances
and covariances of the random variables
involved because of the simplicity of
the method linear estimators are used
quite often especially in systems where
estimates need to be computed quickly in
real time as observations are obtained
we will look into some of the
mathematical properties of the linear
least mean squares estimator and The
Associated mean squared error revisit an
example from the previous lecture and
finally close with some comments on the
ways that this estimator can be used